my god how's it going up great it's a
really good big surprise hey how you
doing I'm spider-man
nice to me what's your name Nicholas
nice to meet how you doing so do you
like Batman better than you spy on me oh
why is that
what's better about Batman huh oh they
really make sense for you that's awesome
buddy
have you seen
oh my god that was so great I mean of
course the little kid wearing Batman on
his shirt probably likes Batman more
than anybody else but I just love that
they captured this on camera this is so
great do you like that man better than
spider-man oh yeah oh sick burn if you
couldn't understand what the little kid
said he actually said pooh pooh that was
his reason he gave Tom Holland for why
Batman is better than spider-man you
know it doesn't really make sense but
sure buddy that's great so if you
haven't seen it recently a lot of the
Marvel movies have been visiting
children's hospitals it's called like
the lollipop theatre thing and it's
basically like a charity that just
brings movie stars you know in costume
like spider-man here to see sick
children so it's actually a really cool
charity and they actually did the same
thing a little while ago you may have
seen pictures from it like here Tom
Holland visiting children in hospital
just getting them super pumped up about
spider-man is like the best thing ever
they actually did it with the thor
ragnarok cast - Chris Hemsworth Tom
Hiddleston while they were filming in
Australia filming the movie they went to
see Hospital children they took Thor's
hammer they let the kids hit Tom
Hiddleston with the hammer hey buddy you
need a hand yeah we got your back if you
do all right here with you man this is a
low key here and I'm Thor and we're here
with juice TV and it's coming what is it
that you're getting to be a superhero
and super villain well it is very cool
especially when I face this particular
supervillain yeah it's very mystery
abuse and it's got lots of tricks and so
on up your sleeve so you're watching
it's a bit shifty and we're brothers um
not in real life obviously so as is like
the new trend for you know big movies
like this to do outreach go visit
children just because little kids
idolize superheroes and you know these
big comic book films are made for
families too so it's one of my favorite
new trends from like these big corporate
entities that you traditionally wouldn't
view in such a positive light but one of
the most fun things for people like
Chris Pratt to do is dress up as
star-lord and go visit children in
hospitals even did it last year with
Chris Evans because it was the New
England Patriots and the Seahawks so
they were like on opposite sides like
you have star-lord
for one team you have Captain America
rooting for the other so they turned
into this big charity thing where they
both ended up dressing up in costume and
going to visit children so you guys can
let me know like what do you think about
like these new superhero movies doing a
lot of charity outrage do you like it
that they're going to visit children and
hospitals do you think they should be
doing something else I feel like this is
probably one of the biggest reasons why
people like Robert Downey jr. and like
the other actors that have been around
for a long time continue to play the
characters because they get to do stuff
like this so they get to impact people's
lives in a much more real tangible way
like you know you see a really awesome
movie you get really jazzed up about it
like you see your superheroes that you
really like doing stuff that's really
cool but when you actually get to meet
them in real life especially when you're
a little kid it's just so far above and
beyond
but as cool as this is there's a whole
bunch of other spider-man stuff
happening recently so if you don't know
who lin-manuel is he's just like a
fairly notable actor associated with
Hamilton but he does a lot of other
stuff he said that he really wants to
play carnage in the spider-man movies
like the Marvel spider-man movies so
I'll be doing a video about that later I
want to do like my Kevin Feige Marvel
vs. DC vs. x-men video next just want to
do two spider-man videos back-to-back
but be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and let me know if there are any
spider-man comic book storylines that
you want me to do videos for because
obviously the movies have their own
thing that they're doing but they tend
to weave in a lot of comic book stuff
like you see Ned leads here who is the
future Hobgoblin in the spider-man
universe so even though I don't think
we're going to be seeing a lot of
Hobgoblin stuff in this first spider-man
homecoming movie they're not going to
completely ignore the fact that he will
eventually become that character so you
have like this really awesome friend of
Peter Parker's in high school that
eventually becomes one of his big
villains so they're kind of doing that
with the entire spider-man homecoming
cast almost everybody is playing a
really big character and just to follow
up on the Mary Jane scindia stuff she's
been adamant over and over about how she
is not playing Mary Jane she's like
that'd be really cool but that's not me
at all in the movie so you can let me
know if you think that she's totally
lying
because Marvel has a gun to her head
like they actually have a team of people
that go around and censor people
working for them so they don't spoil
stuff for the movie or do you think
she's telling the truth in the character
she's playing as somebody that's totally
different
like Michelle Gonzalez who's like a
really badass spider-man character but
obviously not anywhere near Mary Jane
and I almost forgot there's a trailer
rumor so a lot of you been asking me
about a potential trailer dropping in
the next couple of weeks like them
attaching spider-man homecoming to rogue
one so I mean we'll find out like if it
drops it drops and if not then it'll
probably drop during the Superbowl but
if I hear anything then I'll totally do
a video about it obviously if there's
footage I'll totally do a video about it
too so new Kevin Feige Marvel vs. DC
posting next that'll probably be
Thursday morning well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for tom
holland talking about being in the
Avengers and spider-man movies and you
can click here to learn all about the
Doctor Strange sequels the stories I
think they should do thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you